[Music]
Hello, I'm Dr. Patti Brennan. I'm the
Director of the National Library of
Medicine. As a nurse and an industrial
engineer, I've spent my career making
sure that information is available to
help people make everyday health choices
and to support biological and medical
discoveries. At the National Library of
Medicine, we provide trusted information
to scientists, to society, and to people living everyday with healthcare
challenges.
For over 200 years the
National Library of Medicine has been a
partner in biological discovery, clinical
care decision-making, and health care
choices in everyday living.
We began humbly as a small collection of
books in the 1800s and now have grown to
massive genomic data banks, accessible
worldwide, every day by millions of people.
As one of the 27 institutes and
centers here at the National Institutes
of Health, we have three primary missions.
First, we have researchers that develop
the tools that translate health data
into health information and health
action. Second, we serve society by
collecting the world's biological
and biomedical literature; making it
useful to scientists through our PubMed
resource and to everyday people through
MedlinePlus. Finally, we have a mission
for outreach to make the National
Library of Medicine's resources
accessible to everyone through our 7,000
points of presence around the United
States. We make sure that
the resources of the National Library of
Medicine are available through public
libraries, through hospital libraries, and
in schools and clinics. Making all of the
resources of the National Library of
Medicine available to the public
requires a very large workforce. We have
over 1,700 women and men working here.
We have librarians, computer scientists,
researchers, and biological scientists.
We have individuals who understand clinical care and who understand how to educate
the public. We work together to make sure we can deliver, 24 hours a day seven days
a week,
trusted health information.
Thank you for visiting us today. We hope
you'll join with us as we begin our
third century, bringing health
information to scientists and society,
accelerating biomedical discovery,
improving healthcare, and ensuring health
for all globally.